devant les célébrations devant ma
famille devant mes parents demeurent
floues d'oeuvre horaire ma gang de
malades dans la section 300 avec leurs
banderoles drapeaux
c'est incroyable de vis avec
avec tout les gens qui ont été derrière
moi mais plus de début 50 moins cher que
je peu près d'oublier mais ont célébré à
juste titre depuis dimanche laurent
duverne interdit l'exploit d'avoir
remporté avec les chiefs le super bowl
mais genève où ça s'est intensifié un
tout petit peu mais ce matin on doit
également célébré deux personnes qui ont
contribué à la vie aux exploits de leur
rendu vers des terres 10 ses parents
ghislain du vernet et françois tardif
qui sont rentrés de floride on vous
retrouve heb êtes vaillant vous êtes
déjà là boulanger vous êtes prêts
apparemment que du café ça sent le pain
et l'eau vous vous trouvez bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin
bonjour j'ai commencé avec vous guilhem
aviez vous l'impression qu'il y avait
autant de gens qui suivaient ce match là
qu'ils étaient intéressés par tout ça
êtes vous surpris par l'ampleur des
réactions
oui je suis surprise mais à la fois à la
fois je comprends tout cet engouement là
c'est quand même exceptionnel ce qui
arrive avec le parcours de laurent alors
est en fait ce qui me touche le plus de
france de voir tous les tous les gens au
québec qui ont suivi leur rang qui était
derrière lui alors c'est très touchant
c'était tout simplement s'appuie
oui impressionné mais en même temps
heureuse pour l'heure françois il ya eu
les célébrations a vu quelques images là
après le match mais j'aimerais savoir
comment vous avez vécu cette rencontre
là et il ya eu l'avant ce dès chiefs au
début de la rencontre mais un troisième
cas très difficile il paraît même que
vous êtes allé pendant une marche à
l'extérieur des gradins vous êtes sans
doute les seuls qui sort du match pour
aller prendre l'air paraît-il ouais
c'était complètement fou nous on était
bon un petit groupe ensemble comme
mettons la gagne alors est divisé en
deux les jeunes les vieux à peu près on
était les vieux et puis on est entouré
aussi de partisans des fortunes a une
qui était vraiment intense certaines
choses et puis là la partie
effectivement à s'est déroulé pour moi
en deux temps un premier temps où cette
somme tout allait bien les deux premiers
corps et puis on se disait on a une
machine qui est capable de faire des
points rapidement
mais là au troisième quart puis au début
du quatrième quart un magnet je ne
pouvais plus je peux pas vous dire
exactement où c'était mais oui je les
prends un match que j'ai oublié de
respirer je pense les vingt dernières
minutes
et là je me sentais mal que tu as les
marchés en arrière sur bonne et je dis
ok là tout ce que je peux faire c'est de
crier le plus fort que je peux leur
m'avoir venu mêlant mais j'avais plus de
voir et puis et puis je suis arrivé à
peu près ça a donné en même temps que
les six ou huit dernières minutes du
dernier quart et puis c'était cette
attente est maintenant mieux avec une
belle feinte vous avez eu un accès
privilégié aux terrains y avait que
trois passes pour aller voir
laurent madame du vernet qu'est ce que
laurent vous l'a dit on l'a vu vous
parler à l'oreille qu'est ce qui vous a
dit à ce moment là c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable
c'était le mot le mot qui utilisait sa
dépasser ça dépassait ses textes est
comme un peu surréel tout ça puis c'est
comme françois disait à la fin tout est
allé tellement vite
on a à peine réaliser en mondiaux ont
gagné c'était vraiment étrange comme
sensation c'est comme si pour ma part
c'est comme si un moment émouvant mon
cerveau a été d'analyser ce qui se passe
sur le jeu puis tout à coup et c'était
fini puis à lecce j'avais gagné alors
c'était assez serré vous êtes les
parents type et qui de tous les parents
au pays qui suivent leurs enfants mais
vous n'êtes pas des grands fans de
football seul laurent l'a dit qu'est ce
que ça vous fait comme parade de voir
que leur a eu des succès aussi
retentissant aussi rapidement
[Musique]
en fait moi j'ai attributions notre note
par familiale en guise mais c'est le ski
de fond et puis on a un je fais ça
d'ailleurs j'arrivais la veille de cette
randonnée l'acquis et du ski hors piste
une cinquantaine de kilomètres par jour
et puis les enfants ont tout fait cet
cette randonnée leurs plus jeunes
et puis ça l'est vraiment fort juges
pensent que leur volonté de réussir
s'ils te fait 50 km à 12 ans d'un truc
quatre jours en ligne
y'a plus rien d'impossible pour pour toi
fait que tu tu peux continuer donc celle
le départ je pense de tout ça alors nous
effectivement le baseball le football
pardon supprime toutes parts mais on a
pris tranquillement suivant leur renvoi
et puis maintenant je le devais juste
assez bons pour suivre une partie de
football mais on n'est pas des fans
finis effectivement mais je pense
qu'après après le câble de laurens
on sera pas autant fan finie que ben on
est on suivra pas autant le football
bon je présume vous allez peut-être
suivre le défilé par contre à l'heure du
lunch mais entretemps fo je vous dise au
nom de tous les paroles qui vous écoute
qui compte c'est entre villa vous êtes
une sacrée source d'inspiration tout cas
si on fait la moitié aussi bien vous je
crois qu'on va avoir un assez bon succès
merci beaucoup de m'avoir vous êtes
occupé de vos trois petits comme ça qui
semble assez bien aller merci beaucoup
mais très bonne journée
bonne journée